hundreds of submissions
five finalists
three
judges
one
winner
this is the daily wire search for the
official sweet baby gang anthem
[Music]
hello everybody and welcome to the
search for the sweet baby gang anthem i
am your host michael knowles i am joined
by my fellow daily wire hosts ben
shapiro
andrew clavin
and the man of the hour
matt walsh
now the winner of this contest is in for
a real treat
he will get
all of our most recent books he will
also become a part of the matt walsh
show legacy he will be featured in his
very song at the introduction to the
reading the comments section of matt's
show now matt
i am told that the sweet baby gang
has a special name for you they do they
do
sweet daddy walsh what's that my
official name daddy walsh do you expect
to be addressed likewise by all of you
yes daddy
thank you drew never mind actually don't
call me that are you sure papa daddy all
right i've changed my mind andrew clavin
what do you want
the leader of clavinon the master of the
multiverse
where were you when you first heard of
the sweet baby gang
i was sitting here during the
introduction
to say that this is i this may be the
most humiliating moment of my life i i
looked at that picture of the baby walsh
and i i now have a tick i have a small
twitch from the trauma and if these
lights flashing around give me a seizure
i am suing ben shapiro back into the
stone age i want you to know that so i'm
thrilled to be here well speaking of ben
shapiro ben
uh it's it's great obviously to have you
as a judge here does it feel weird that
you are going to have to judge on behalf
of your daddy
when do i get to fire everyone
when well you'll get to make at least
some firing decisions when you hear all
of the songs some of them are gonna go
know you're all very excited to get to
the contest so here is how it works we
have taken all of the submissions sent
in over the past week we've narrowed it
down to the top five finalists our
skilled judges are going to listen to
about a minute of each song and after
careful consideration they will select
their top two picks then we turn it over
to you at home after this broadcast you
can log on to dailywire.com
sbg and you will have 24 hours to cast
your vote
for the sweet baby gang anthem
is everybody ready to get started
absolutely
here is our first entry it is titled
theocratic funk by
the sweetest baby
[Music]
whoa it's me
i'm in need of a sweet daddy
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
his polka dots be looking funky fresh
he
[Music]
gentlemen uh drew i'll start with you
what do you think uh you know i would
have aged uh several years just watching
that if i have several more years to
live which i i don't so i think it's a
very dangerous dangerous song for me yep
uh ben
um
that sounded
like a hippopotamus
being hit by an airplane
the remains then being collected
and
burned but then the ashes gathered
and the ashes transformed into a glowing
diamond of
you took us on a journey with that one
song and so did that yeah that yeah matt
what's your take i have to disagree with
my my fellow judges i thought that it
was uh fresh it was current it felt uh
relevant and i also thought that it was
beautiful and the lyrics touched me uh
very very deeply
thought it was tremendous moving along
to our next entry this one is called
walsh's anthem by joshua royal watson
[Applause]
who makes a twitter mob fly off the
handle with rage
who's to blame
it's a sweet baby gang
[Music]
who's rocking polka dot and flannel
shirts without shame
do you know their name
i mean this is pretty good come on
[Music]
drew your thoughts
well you know i have to admit my mind
drifted for a moment i was thinking
about the time i had dignity but
actually that was when i came back that
was that was actually pretty funny i
have to say that was that was amusing it
was mildly immune it was musical it had
some rhythm then
that was better
i mean it was now admittedly the
standard was what came just before it
but still like
on a scale of one to ten
that was at least a four
that's something better than zero
matt
uh i thought it couldn't get better than
the last one and this somehow exceeded
even those expectations i wanted to hear
more of it i mean that's that becomes
music into my ears and it's now the
music of my heart i've found it to be
we very well might hear more of it a
little bit later maybe every single day
on the show but before we make any of
those decisions we have an entry from
andrew werner it's titled
put him up
if you're down
we the sweet babies driving liberals
crazy we play that wire daily no offense
to ben or michael knows candice or
andrew clavin
daddy walsh is our default he never
falters to bring the news and he brings
it greatly leftists claim he's racy he's
every single phobic we'll wipe them
tears i'll get my mug and tell you when
the show is you see the beard you see
the king approaches you hear the babies
asking bender give sweet daddy watch a
big promotion to put them up if you're
down with the baby gang put them up if
you're down with the baby gang sweet
baby gang sweet baby gang sweet baby
gang
ben i'd like to start this time with you
uh your immediate reaction
well
as a platinum award-winning rapper in my
own right
let me just say
that
it's comparing the size and weight of
various piles of steaming
is actually difficult when you don't
have a proper scale
and so you sort of have to just eyeball
it and so to be honest with you between
number one
and number two and they're all number
two but between number one and number
two and number three
number three falls somewhere between one
and two it's not as bad as the first one
oh wow it's not as good as the third one
it's somewhere in the middle but again
we are now just grading gradations of
absolute
horse excrement
wow okay
drew
you know
when i lived in england i i got i had a
hernia and because they have that
universal health care they don't give
you painkillers they literally just give
you aspirin and tell you to have a stiff
upper lip and it was possibly the most
painful experience of my life uh until
this
fair harsh but fair matt
i didn't think it was fair in fact i'm
offended on behalf of these contestants
who put their heart and soul into making
this music and for them to be treated
this way i find to be personally hurtful
to me
and as far as the song went i thought
you know i can imagine
if i could say the homies on the block
bumping that
uh in their rides as they're going down
the street i think it's to me it felt
hip it felt relevant yeah something that
i can imagine the kids are going to
really connect with on on deep level
really speaks to the people and what's
going on in the streets yeah i thought
so i thought so daddy is going to stick
up for his babies no question about it
up next
we've got the sweet baby gang by
globule
[Music]
[Music]
y'all are going crazy
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
simple to the point matt let's start
with you
i mean once again i feel that uh each
each song gets somehow better and better
than the one before it and this again
every single one i think to myself can i
imagine
young people
at a party playing that song
and dancing yep you know
dancing the jig and some polka yeah yeah
and uh and i say for that absolutely i
thought it was a tremendous song yeah
loved every second of it drew
well you know i watched it very closely
and i think the one thing i can say is
just a guess but just from eyeballing it
i feel that uh no animals were hurt
during the making of that song and i
think as long as we i love animals and
as long as we can say that i think we
can safely say the the animals are safe
for another day
bam
so
frankly i think that we should all be
honored that the creator of the theme
two malcolm in the middle
also
wrote this particular theme yeah and i
very much look forward to frankie
munoz's appearance
on the sweet what's it called sweet baby
sweet baby gang sweet baby gang
why
why is it called that for our final
video it comes to us from
the columbia county coyotes
and this is their song
they're a little presumptuous with this
title i think it's called sweet baby
gang anthem
[Music]
we live so much
i'll keep
[Music]
got a real monkey's vibe from that one
maybe that could be a tv show in itself
ben
you know
history is filled with the stories
of people who make great sacrifices
martyr themselves for great causes you
know the christians sacrificing
themselves to the lions and roman
amphitheaters and the jews before the
spanish inquisition in 1492
and me listening to these songs
history is really you know and i think
one day when people look back at
my life which if i have to listen to any
more of these will be like the
expiration date is moving faster when
they look back and look at my legacy
they're going to think the sacrifices he
made on behalf of the sweet
it's right there it's just a sweet baby
on behalf of that it was a great
sacrifice um
i feel as though someone had taken a
jackhammer planted it directly
in my right temple and then just gone to
town yeah that's kind of what it felt
like to be honest with you robert e lee
has been described as a great man
who gave his career to a terrible cause
drew yeah i thought you were describing
me there from that i i you know i felt
such a surge of joy when i realized that
this was the last time i was going to
have to see that baby matt walsh
tumbling across the stage except when he
comes to work uh that i i may have kind
of overrated this song i you know i
enjoyed the baby i like babies babies
are cute you know and uh and so uh it
was awful it was just real i'm sorry
terrible i was trying to say something
nice but i just couldn't get there
i tried yeah
matt
uh just picking up on ben's sort of
theological spiritual theme i when i was
listening to that song i could really
imagine myself at the end of my own life
climbing up uh the steps into the sky
and
the pearly gates open and the choirs of
angels are singing that song
that's what i was thinking
those beautiful songs what i mean
judges in front of you is an official
sweet baby ballot
i need you to highlight your top two
finalists
all right let's collect these ballots
i'll give it a quick
quick look around here right so
we've got uh drew all right
he's got two two choices there i'm not
sure i totally agree with them but
that's fine we've got ben included a
little message there on on his it would
seem
a little sos and uh matt
matt highlighted the the entire ballot
i thought they were all
they're all winners in my book this is
how joe biden became president
so
the
i suppose there's a bit of a tie can we
play them all again and
no reflect no
paper on this
in the event of a tie i don't know if
the judges the judges back there or the
the producers can can i be a
tie-breaking
vote i don't what
is that all right good i'm glad because
i actually i'm actually a little bit
scandalized
here they are the two finalists are
walsh's anthem by joshua royal waffen
and put them up if you're down by andrew
warner
audience
now it's all up to you
the polls are open they're ready to
receive your votes
visit dailywire.com
sbg and support the song that you want
as your sweet baby gang anthem voting
will close at 2pm eastern standard time
on september 7th so share the link
across all your social media pages to
see your favorite song your absolute
favorite song
become the winner
now before we go all of us here at the
daily wire would like to say a sincere
thank you to everyone who participated
in this contest mean comments
notwithstanding although we could not
show every entry that we received here's
a look at a few honorable mentions that
we wanted to highlight we hope you enjoy
them as much as we did
thank you for joining us and in the
words of matt walsh
go by speechless today
and godspeed
[Music]
now the most impressed person i know is
mr walsh who leads the show and that's
okay he's got the game
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
twisted mind
our favorite
[Music]
you're banned from the show
listen to me closely while i'm
believe still aliens and live in the
american dream come georgia sweet
sweet baby cane
[Music]
we're the sweet baby gang and we're all
pro-american
together we stand up against all that's
orwellian
where the sweet baby gang with
[Music]
and we'll leave it there
[Music]